we're gonna jump into the deep end
everybody
uh last week I wrote this because it
dawned on me that um R Kelly missed a
couple opportunities
let me let me land the plane everybody
let me lay on the plane all right
here we go I figured this is a song he
could have written for a hit
one
time in my life oh I met a girl
we went back to my place
we were rolling around
she stopped the fun she said right to my
face pee on me
I'm into that
unless you just stayed a spiritus
and I said fine
but we're on my bed we'll have to find
another place
if you wanna get paid on
she just walked to the bathtub and lay
down down I'm ready to get
on and I got a little stage right yeah
nothing came out it's hard to pee when
someone is staring at you pee on me
power of your golden shower
ready to get
peed on and I said okay but it's hard to
pee on someone else
when you have gods
a fully
erection that's all I got right now
[Applause]